the governor's award honors artists and
craftsmen whose influence has
transcended their particular field this
is true of all of our honorees tonight
and it is certainly true of frederick
wiseman whose observational style has
had an impact far beyond non fiction
film as a filmmaker fred is a unique
chronicler of our culture and
particularly our institutions that form
the basic but often hidden structure of
our society patient unwavering and
relentlessly curious Fred researches his
films by shooting them and writes the
stories in the editing room as a
testament to Fred's honesty you only
have to look at it occurred Follies a
film that was banned for Jenner for
general audiences for 24 years for
revealing that uncomfortable truth about
how we treat the mentally ill in this
country in more than 50 years of
documentary filmmaking fred has never
lost his fascination with ordinary lives
and has never blinked at the
uncomfortable truths he is uncovered
thank you for sharing these stories with
us Fred we are all better for it I want
to thank you on behalf of K demand and
Roger Ross Williams my fellow
documentary governors for the
documentary branch for the governor's
branch for your influence not only on
documentaries for your influence on
filmmaking and your influence on each of
us as individuals and the impact that
you've had on all of our lives I'm so
grateful to you so happy you're winning
this on board tonight here's to you Fred